[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Danny Iny has been
feature than the Harvard
Business Review Entrepreneur,
and he contributes regularly
to publications, including Inc,
Forbes, and Business Insider.
He has guest lectured at
McGill University, as well as
Yale University, and he's the
author of multiple bestselling
books about online education.
His most recent book,
"Leveraged Learning."
It's hot off the presses.
It just came out in October.
And it's the culmination
of Danny's research
into the latest work
in neuroscience,
instructional design, and recent
breakthroughs in education.
The book aims to sow the seeds
of education's transformation
in the coming years.
So please welcome Danny
to Google New York.
[APPLAUSE]
DANNY INY: Thank you.
It's a privilege to be here.
So once upon a time,
there was an emperor who
was powerful and influential.
And all of his
strengths and resources
were exceeded only
by his vanity.
He wanted the most wonderful,
resplendent refinery that
could be found in all the land.
But where was he to find
this wonderful, resplendent
refinery?
There was no Google.
He could not type
in where it is.
So he put out an RFP.
He had his missives go out to
all the tailors in the land
saying, bring to us your plans.
Bring to us your sketches.
Bring to us your fabrics.
And the tailors did.
They came to the
royal court, and they
paraded in front of him, and
they displayed their wares,
and he was never satisfied.
Until finally two men
approached the emperor.
They said, Sire, we have
the most wonderful garment
that we can create for
you, of a magical fabric
of unsurpassed beauty.
And the emperor was excited.
This is what he wanted--
the best of the very best.
And so he had his men bring
a giant chest of gold coins
to these two men.
They took the chest
of gold coins,
and they went away to work,
except they didn't work,
because they weren't tailors.
They were conmen.
So they goofed off
for a few weeks
while they were
supposed to be working.
Then, they returned
to the royal palace.
And they said, Sire,
we have brought
to you this wonderful,
incredible garment.
But we must tell you
something important about it.
You see, it is made
of a magical fabric.
And all who are wise or
worthy who gaze upon it
will see the most beautiful
construction they've ever
seen with their eyes.
But those who are
not worthy, those
who are not deserving of their
post, those who are incompetent
will see nothing.
And then one of the tailors
reaches into his bag,
he pulls out his arm,
and he's holding nothing.
And the court is smiling
nervously, because they're all
thinking, am I the only one?
I don't want to be deemed
unworthy and incompetent,
because being deemed as
incompetent and unworthy
inside the emperor's court
soon leads to being beheaded
outside the emperor's court.
And so they all
smiled nervously.
And the emperor, not wanting
to lose face in front
of his subjects, said, wow.
What gorgeous refinery.
I am thrilled.
And he made a show of
putting on nothing--
and give them their gold coins
and sent them on their way.
And then, finally, he says,
I want the entire kingdom
to see the great beauty and
wonder that I now get to wear.
So he organizes a parade.
And he's marching down the
street with fanfare and music.
And all his subjects are
smiling nervously and cheering.
Until finally, a small boy looks
at him and begins to giggle
and says, mommy, the
emperor is naked.
And as parents, we've all
had those mortifying moments.
And that's how the
parents felt for a moment.
But then, the crowd
bursts out laughing.
Because, of course,
they had realized
that the emperor was naked.
Now this is an old story.
It was written by Hans Christian
Andersen almost 200 years ago.
The emperor has no clothes
is an allegory for something
that everyone knows is
not true, but nobody
acknowledges it's not true.
And for that final moment,
when the little boy points
at the emperor, says,
"the emperor is naked,"
everyone bursts
out laughing, there
are two awakenings
that have to occur.
First, there's the
private awakening.
This is the individual citizens
gazing upon the emperor
and thinking to
themselves, I don't
think he's wearing any clothes.
And that stays inside them.
Later, there's a
public awakening
when they call out the emperor.
Now it takes a very
different thing
to have that private awakening
and then to make it public.
The private awakening
happens when
you have an impression
based on your experiences,
based on your thoughts,
based on your perspective.
The public awakening happens
when you feel strongly enough
about it and you
feel that you can
support the argument with enough
rigor when others disagree.
Now emperors can be people,
but more often their ideas,
their institutions.
And the biggest emperor
in our modern world
is higher education.
We orient our entire
lives around it.
We spend the first 18
years working to get in,
we spend the next 18
years paying it off,
and another 18 years saving
up so that our kids can
start the same process.
I had both of these awakenings
about higher education.
And these two awakenings were
prompted by two pivotal moments
in my life.
The first was when
I was 15 years old.
Now a little bit of back story.
As a child, I was the goody
two shoes, teacher's pet,
always gets perfect
straight A's.
I was that kid.
And that worked for
me until about the end
of the eighth grade.
But then I got into
the ninth grade,
and it was like a switch
flipped in my head.
And I sat there in class.
And I just thought
to myself, oh my god.
I'm so bored.
I can't take this anymore.
And so I started
cutting classes.
Now here's the thing about me.
I'm a bit of an
extreme personality.
I don't do anything halfway.
And so in that first
trimester of the ninth grade,
I missed 152 classes.
152 classes.
I was barely there.
And the number just
went up from there.
This went on for about
a year and a half,
till about the middle of the
10th grade; I was 15 years old.
And then, I just
had this moment.
I looked in the
mirror, and I paused.
I thought to myself,
Danny, what are you doing?
Like, what's the plan here?
Am I just going to keep cutting
classes, and going to the gym,
and watching MTV all day--
which is what teenagers
did back then.
This doesn't make sense.
So I think it's time.
I'm going to make it official.
I'm going to quit school.
I'm going to start
my first business.
The prevailing narrative
around me at the time
was not encouraging
of this idea.
The prevailing
narrative said, Danny,
you are making a huge mistake.
You are throwing your life away.
Now let's unpack that.
There's two things there.
Danny, you're making
a huge mistake.
Basically saying, the
consequences of this decision
will not be positive.
I disagreed.
I had a different perspective.
But I was like, you know what?
I could see that.
I don't know everything.
I might be wrong.
But here's the thing I
couldn't get on board with.
"You are throwing
your life away."
This implied irreversibility
to the decision--
not just it's the wrong
move, but your life is over.
This is it.
It's the end.
And I thought to myself,
that doesn't make sense.
Like, worst case scenario, I can
always just go back to school.
Like, this is a
reversible decision.
And so I went ahead, and I
dropped out of school thanks
to the support of some people
in my life, especially my mom,
and I started my first business.
And it turns out it was
one of the best decisions I
could have made for myself.
I got to experience
things I never
would have otherwise
experienced,
learned things I never
otherwise would have learned--
played out great.
Now as a little aside, I
want to clarify something.
Because there's a difference
between dropping out, meaning
opting out, meaning
saying, I don't
like the instructions that
have been set out before me,
so I'm just going to quit.
I'm going to opt out.
I'm going to sit on a couch,
watch TV, and eat pizza
all day long.
That's not just
dropping out of school.
That's dropping out of life.
There's a huge
difference between that
and saying, I'm opting
into something else.
I'm going to take a
self-directed and curious
approach, and I trust that
I will find a way to do it.
So I'm not advocating that
anyone drop out, opt out,
and that's it.
I think opting for something
better is worthwhile.
So that was the first instance.
I was 15.
I dropped out of school.
And it worked out pretty well.
Now, let's go on to this
second crossroads in my life.
I'm going to fast
forward 10 years.
Now I'm about 25.
And in those
intervening 10 years,
I had been involved in a whole
bunch of different businesses I
had gotten to do a whole
bunch of interesting projects.
And, most recently, I had tried
to build a software company.
We were developing technology
that taught kids how to read,
which is something I always
cared a great deal about.
And we raised some money
from friends and family.
We got some really good early
traction with our prototype.
The experts loved it.
The kids loved it.
But the parents
and the teachers,
who were the actual
customers, they didn't get it.
I was a very young
and very inexperienced
CEO in what, in hindsight, is
the most complicated industry
on the face of the earth.
And by the time this young and
inexperienced CEO figured out
what I needed to do and
how things need to go,
we were almost out of money,
and it was August of 2008.
In September of 2008,
the markets crashed.
The bottom fell out
from under everyone.
And I walked away from that
experience with about $250,000
in personal debt.
It was not a great
time in my life.
And when you have
that kind of setback,
you question your decisions.
You question the
path you've taken.
You think maybe I need
a little more security.
Maybe I need a little
more stability.
Maybe there's some virtue
to a more traditional path.
And I said, what if
I go back to school?
What if I go to business
school and get my MBA?
So I applied to schools.
I got into one of the top
business schools in Canada.
I didn't have a high
school diploma, by the way.
Because even institutions
of higher learning
that value higher learning,
they have exception paths
for people who have
interesting backgrounds,
and interesting experience,
and who are resourceful enough.
So even institutions
of higher learning
don't actually value
the traditional path
as much as they pretend.
But I got into one of the top
business schools in Canada.
And the prevailing narrative
around me this time
was, Danny, this is great.
You are going to set
yourself up for life.
You're going to learn the
things you need to learn.
It's going to open
all the doors.
This is the best thing
you can possibly do.
So the expectation is
that the consequences
would be uniformly good.
Nobody talked
about reversibility
or irreversibility.
Who wants to reverse something
that's going to be all good?
Well, I went ahead, I
committed the time and very
substantial amount
of money that it took
to go through this program.
I earned my degree.
And as it turns out, if I had
to make a list of the 5 or 10
worst investments of time
and money in my life,
this would be high on that list.
I had some great
teachers, but I also
had a lot of mediocre ones.
I met some interesting people.
I also met a lot
of mediocre ones.
The brochures promised all the
future leaders of tomorrow.
The class held all the
middle managers of today.
So it was not an
impressive experience.
It was certainly not
worth the investment.
And, again, a clarifying
point, people will often say,
Danny, wait, are you
saying you're better off
without an MBA than with one?
The answer is no, of course not.
But it's not about am I better
off with it or without it.
The question is, am
I better off with it
or with the other
things I could have
done with that time and money.
And the answer is, I could
have done much better things
with that time and money.
So it's about the
opportunity costs,
and it wasn't worthwhile.
Now the contrast between
these two junctures in my life
was interesting.
Dropping out of high
school at the age of 15,
everyone said it would
be a terrible idea
with irreversible
consequences, neither
of those turned out to be true.
And going back to
school, getting my MBA,
everyone thought it
would be a great move,
but it wasn't, and it was
completely irreversible.
I can never get that
time or that money back.
What I've since found is
that these experiences,
less the high school thing--
because most people stick it
through at least that far--
but especially the outcomes
and experience people
have with higher education, this
was not a unique experience.
Digging into the data,
I found that if you
look at postgraduate
employment, look at people age
22 to 29 who have a college
degree, almost half of them
are underemployed,
meaning they're
working in a job that does
not require a college degree.
So they traded four
or more years--
it takes the average American
seven years to complete
a four-year program--
"four-year program--" so they
traded four to seven years
of their lives, tens if
not hundreds of thousands
of dollars-- the average
American graduates from
an undergraduate program
with over $30,000 in debt,
which you figure in the interest
they're going to pay over
the life of the debt
is more like $46,000--
they traded that
time in that money
to get a job that does not
even require a college degree.
And off the balance
of these slightly more
than 50% of people age 22 to
29 with a college degree who
are working in a job that
requires a college degree,
three quarters of them
are working in a field
that is not what they studied.
So how much credit can
the degree really take?
That's kind of messed up.
Now I want to be clear.
I'm not saying that
all college is bad.
America's top schools have
a lot to offer besides just
the academics, and
there are few schools
that are innovating in
really interesting ways.
If you look at Western
Governors in Utah,
if you look at Arizona State,
you look at Northeastern,
you look at the University
of Southern New Hampshire,
there's some really
interesting things happening.
But many people don't have great
experiences or great ROIs, even
at the top schools, and most
schools are not top schools.
Of the thousands of colleges
and universities in the US,
only about 200 of them are
what you can call selective,
meaning they accept less than
50% of the people who apply.
So you get a mixed experience
at those top 200 schools,
and most schools are
not anywhere near
that level of quality.
Now all of that, my
experiences and then
finding this data, that led to
my private awakening of, OK,
the emperor is not
wearing any clothes.
There's something messed
up about higher education
and people's
expectations from it.
And I could have
just stopped there.
I could have just been part
of the massive disillusioned
silent masses.
But there are two
quirks to my personality
that took it further.
The first is that I am
fascinated and inspired
by education.
Now I'm not unique in being
fascinated and inspired
by something.
Everyone is fascinated
and inspired by something.
For me, that's education.
I just find it magical, not the
education industrial complex,
which I think is a disaster,
but education, the process
of empowering
people to do things
they weren't
formally able to do.
There's a great quote that
I love by Walt Disney.
"If you can dream
it, you can do it."
countless.
People have been
inspired to great action
by this quote, this
idea, myself included.
And I'm inspired
by the possibility
of what we can dream.
But I'm also fascinated by
the fundamental untruth of it.
If you can dream it, that
doesn't mean you can do it.
There's a world of a gap
between dreaming and doing.
And that gap is
bridged by education.
So that just fascinates
me personally.
I think it's amazing that we
can spend a day watching videos
on Ted and be inspired by all
the amazing things we know how
to do, all the amazing
problems we know how to solve,
then we close our laptop,
we walk out into the world,
we look around, we're
like, where is all of it?
That gap between what we could
do and what we actually do,
that's what education does.
That's really cool to me.
The second quirk
about my personality
is that when I'm
fascinated by something,
when I'm excited about
something, I talk about it.
So when I was a kid,
when I was four years old
or whatever in kindergarten,
I'd come home from school
and I'd say, mommy, mommy,
look at this thing I made.
And she'd look at and
say, that's amazing.
What's it supposed to be?
But I was excited, and I
would do that every day.
And that hasn't changed.
I write books.
I write articles.
And I'll come home at the end
of the day with a printout
and say, sweetie, my
wife, sweetie, look,
look, you've got to read
this article I wrote
and tell me what you think.
I'm telling you about
the meeting I had.
I am excited about something,
and I want to talk about it.
That just hasn't changed.
So being excited about,
fascinated by education,
and also frustrated and
disillusioned with the way
that it works in real life,
and having a propensity
to talk about it means
that I found myself
in a lot of positions
to get a lot of pushback
from people who disagreed.
Because after all, the
people I have the privilege
of talking to are smart.
They're educated.
And people, as a
whole, human beings,
are invested in the things
they have invested in.
Dan Ariely is research
into the IKEA effect
has shown that when we
build something ourselves,
we value it more highly than if
someone else built it for us.
Back when fraternity
hazings were
a kind of sort of
acceptable thing,
the rationalization was,
well, I went through it.
And look, it worked out for
me, and so I must be invested.
Otherwise, what was the point?
We are invested in the things
that we have invested in.
And so there was all this
pushback, all this, well, no,
education is important.
It broadens your horizons,
and it opens doors,
and it's not even
about the classes.
It's about the network.
And the excuses
would go on and on.
Every time I would have
a counter argument,
they'd jump to a different one.
And there's something
more fundamental
going on there, which is
that people don't want
to make the wrong
choice with the most
sensitive and important
decisions they'll
make in their lives.
There's an old
saying in business.
Nobody ever got
fired for buying IBM.
People used to say that.
IBM was in a different
business then.
Well, no one ever
said that you're
a bad parent because you sent
your kid to college, right?
If you don't, a lot of
people might say that.
Nobody ever said you're throwing
your life away because you're
going to college.
There's this fear
of getting it wrong.
And this was the thing
that really struck me.
I would talk to
people, even people
who agreed with me completely
about how fundamentally broken
higher education is, how bad of
a return on investment people
were getting, and
they were still
conflicted about the idea of not
sending their kids to college.
It felt dangerous.
It felt almost heretical.
And that's what's weird to me.
How could you look at the
numbers, look at the data,
know that it's a bad
deal and still think,
but I think it's too
dangerous not to do it?
And that led me to do more
research, to dig deeper.
Remember, I have an
extreme personality.
So I don't do things halfway.
So I started reading
articles, and I started
listening to interviews.
And I started
talking to experts.
And I started reading books.
And I came back to the
people who pushed back,
and I had counter
arguments for them.
And they had counter
arguments for me.
And so I went back
and did more research,
and this cycle accelerated
over a seven-year period
until this kind of passive,
fun thing that I was doing
became, no, no, no.
I'm taking this on.
This is a research project.
So I went onto Amazon,
and I ordered every book
I could find about education,
instructional design,
the science of learning,
education reform.
And the books arrived.
Then, I looked at the
references in the back,
and I ordered all the books
that they were referring to.
And I had a mountain
of books in my house.
My wife was like, Danny,
what are you doing?
And I looked at this
mountain of books
and I was like, what am I doing?
There's no way I can
read all these books
in a human lifetime.
And so I hired a research team.
I said, I want you
to read this book
and write me a 20 or 30-page
summary with page stamps
so I can go back to the
original source of every idea
and chase it down.
And I spent tens of thousands
of dollars getting a library
summarized so that I can
dig into, and research,
and organize, and think through.
I'm a little obsessive.
So I did all this.
And all of that
research culminated
into "Leverage
Learning," the book
that I published in October.
Now I did all this
research looking for, once
and for all, the definitive
data that I could show people
saying, look, this
direction in which I'm
saying education is
going, look, the data
is saying that's really
where it's going.
What I actually found in the
data is that it's already here.
There is a great quote
by William Gibson.
He said, "The future is here.
It's just not
evenly distributed."
The future is here.
It's just not
evenly distributed.
So what does that mean?
Well, let me tell
you a little story.
A couple of years ago, I was on
a business trip at a layover,
so I'm hanging out at the
airport killing some time.
And I see a Brookstone store.
It's the store has all the
interesting tech gadgets.
And having time to kill
and liking interesting tech
gadgets, I step inside.
And I see on display a Yoda
doll, Yoda from "Star Wars,"
like this big on a pedestal.
And as I approach,
Yoda's eyes open,
and he turns his head
a little bit towards me
and he says, teach you
to use the force, I will.
I'm like, cool, OK.
And Yoda says,
stretch out your arm.
And so I'm kind of
tentatively doing this.
And through some combination
of sensors and motors,
Yoda gets flung back.
I'm like, oh my god!
This is so cool.
I need to buy this
and bring it home.
And then, of course, I thought,
this won't fit in my carry-on,
and my wife will kill me.
So I'm not going to buy
it, but this was awesome.
Thank you very much.
And I keep walking
in the airport,
and I step into the
men's room, and I
see a line of men in front
of a line of sinks waving
their hands frantically trying
to get the motion activated
faucet to release some water.
The future is here.
It's just not
evenly distributed.
The sensors will get
into the faucets, too,
it's just a matter of time.
Now what does that
mean about education.
Has the whole world
caught onto the fact
that education is broken?
Not yet, but they are.
It's happening.
Is education broken already?
Yes, it is, and people
are catching on to that.
And when we're making big
decisions about our education,
we have to think
ahead because you're
going to have to live with the
consequences of the decision
in the world that exists in
four to seven years, not today.
So what does this mean for
the disruption of education?
We hear a lot about the rising
cost of education, the student
debt crisis.
It's $1.5 trillion now in the
US, second only to mortgages.
It's more than credit cards.
It is also, by the
way, the only kind
of debt you can't
even free yourself
by declaring bankruptcy.
It's also the kind
of debt you're
most likely to incur before
you're even a legal adult.
Pretty crazy.
So we hear a lot about
the debt, the cost,
but we don't hear a lot
about the other side
of the equation, which is what
is all that money paying for?
What is it actually buying?
Now we've already talked about
post-graduation employment
rates, which are abysmal.
They're a disaster.
But there's a whole lot more.
There's all this
stuff that we think
is true, all these truisms
about the value of college
that just doesn't add up.
Let's take, for example, the
lie of lifetime earnings.
We've all heard the truism.
If you go to college, you'll
make more over your lifetime.
Well, that's accurate,
but it's also misleading
because you're looking at
a massive amount of data
as a whole rather than looking
at the right pockets of it.
So let's start with
a little analogy.
Imagine you've got a bar, and
10 guys are sitting in the bar,
and they each are in the
median American household
income of about $60,000.
And then Bill Gates
walks into the bar.
The average income of
a person at the bar
just shot up by over
a billion dollars.
But none of those
guys got any richer.
So it's true that, as a
whole, college graduates
earn more over a
lifetime than people who
didn't go to college.
But let's filter out
those top 200 schools
which represent less than
10%, much less than 10%,
of college education in the US.
Let's take that out
of the equation.
Let's also take
out of the equation
a very small subset of highly
paid vocation granting degrees.
So we take out engineering and
medical school, for example.
Most of those earnings
differences disappear.
Let's also remember that most
colleges are in major metro
areas, which means that
most college graduates are
in major metro areas,
where the cost of living
is a little higher and the
income is a little higher.
Let's also remember that
if you graduate saddled
with enormous
amounts of debt, you
will have a bias to take a
higher paying job you might not
want, because you have no
choice, to service that debt.
Let's also remember that just
about all post-college earning
data is self-reported.
So the people who are excited
about how much money they're
making will presumably
be overrepresented.
So figure all that in, and
that difference disappears.
And it goes further.
Because there's also a
question of attribution.
Let's look at the top schools.
Let's look at, you go to one
of those top 200 schools,
you will earn more
over a lifetime.
But is that because you went
to the top school therefore
you're earning more?
Or is it because the people who
were going to earn more anyway
went to the top school?
It's harder to get
into the top schools.
It takes a higher caliber
person, as judged by academics
and whatever else.
That can be a
confounding variable.
So research has
actually been done
to try to untangle
those variables
Seth Stephens-Davidowitz,
he published a great book
the last couple of years.
It's called "Everybody Lies."
He got a lot of his data from
Google, which is fascinating.
So what he did is
he looked at the--
because do we know that people
who graduated from Harvard
earn more over a
lifetime than people
who went to Penn State, which
a good, but not quite as good
school?
Yes, but it's harder
to get into Harvard.
So he looked at the data.
He looked at the
people who applied to
and got accepted to both
Harvard and Penn State.
They could have gone
to either, but they
chose to go to Penn State
because it was closer to home.
It was cheaper.
There was a boyfriend
or girlfriend there,
closer to a family,
whatever it is.
So let's compare that
cohort's postgraduate earning
with the people who
went to Harvard.
It's exactly the same.
So is it that you
make more money
because you went to
Harvard, or is it
that the people who are going
to make more money anyway
went to Harvard?
There's a huge
disconnect between what
we think education will do for
us and what it actually does.
But it raises the question, why?
Why is education so out
of step with modern life?
It wasn't always like this.
100 years ago, 50 years
ago, even 30 years ago,
college really was the golden
ticket to the good life,
to opportunity, to possibility.
It really did open doors.
So what has changed?
Well, over the last
few decades, everything
about how we need education to
fit into our lives has changed,
but education hasn't,
not nearly enough.
So let's start with the
timing of education.
The timing of education
in our lives has changed.
Education used to follow
a just-in-case model.
You're going to spend
a whole bunch of years
studying at the
start of your career
just in case you need it.
And this was always
pedagogical problematic
because we know that the
amount of stuff you retain
is a lot less than people think.
And so the stuff you
studied in college 5, or 10,
or 15 years later, most of
it's just not there anymore.
But let's put that aside.
The stuff that you learned
could still be current.
The world stage more
or less the same.
You could graduate from
college, get a job,
and be doing a similar
job 30 years later better
because you have
more experience,
but it's the same
fundamental skill set.
That's not how our
world works today.
The world changes
so much faster.
I mean, here at
Google, anyone who
learned how to code 20 years ago
and that was their knowledge,
it'd be useless.
They couldn't do
anything, right?
The world has changed.
Larry Summers, the former dean
of Harvard is on record saying,
everything you learn is going
to be obsolete in 5 or 10 years.
So we're shifting.
We're seeing a shift from a
lot of education just in case
at the start of a career to
actually a lot more education
just in time, over the
duration of a career.
The timing of education,
informal institutions
has not kept up
with what we need.
But even more
importantly, the way
in which we need to be empowered
by education has changed.
Compare again the
world 100 years ago,
50 years ago, 30 years
ago with the world today.
It used to be pretty static.
Things stayed more
or less the same.
But now, things are changing
at an ever-faster pace
because of Moore's law, because
of how quickly technology
is changing, because
of automation, because
of AI, because of the
acceleration of all
those factors coming together.
30 years ago, the world
was ruled by experts.
But today, expertise is cheap.
Being an expert
basically means you
can answer the questions
that Google can answer;
and Google is faster.
Now, we need people who
can answer the questions
that Google can't answer, and
that's not the same thing.
30 years ago, a
model employee was
someone who could
follow instructions
with a high degree
of competency.
And education did a pretty
good job of training people
to do exactly that.
But things have changed.
We've all heard
the clichs, right?
You know, the hottest jobs
today didn't exist 15 years ago.
We're training people
to solve problems
that aren't problems
yet using tools
that haven't been invented
yet, et cetera, et cetera.
We've heard those
cliches, and they're true.
But it raises the
question, well, then,
what does it take to
succeed in that world today
and into the future?
Well, let's do a little
thought experiment.
Imagine you're about to
start the most ambitious,
challenging, complicated,
sensitive, high-profile project
of your life and career, but you
don't know anything about it.
Now, build your team.
Who do you want on
your team with you?
You can't say, well, I need
a full stack developer,
and I need a copywriter,
and I need a police chief.
You can't say I need these
things because you don't know
what the subject matter is.
So you're probably
going to say, well,
I want people who are
resourceful and think well
on their feet, people who take
initiative and responsibility,
people who handle
ambiguity well,
and people who play
well with others.
So how does that play
out in the real world?
Think about the
best people you've
worked with in your
careers, the people who
got great results,
delivered great outcomes,
everyone wanted
them on their teams.
I'm willing to bet that other
than their subject matter
expertise, which
is also important--
these are all people who were
resourceful and thought well
on their feet, who took
initiative and responsibility,
who handled ambiguity well, and
who played well with others.
And what do employers
tell us they want?
They want people who are
resourceful and think well
on their feet.
They want people who take
initiative and responsibility.
They want people who
handle ambiguity well.
And they want people who
play well with others.
Competence is no longer enough.
Our world demands excellence.
Memorizing the dots
is no longer enough.
We have Google for that.
Our world demands that
we find novel ways
of connecting those dots.
Knowing the answers
is no longer enough.
Our world demands that we
learn to ask better questions.
So given those needs, how does
higher education stack up?
The answer is, poorly.
Higher education
does a terrible job
of preparing us to think
critically and creatively.
There is a great
body of research.
You can we find the book
called "Academically Adrift"
documenting it, showing
that over a third
of people going through
a four-year college
career as a student shows zero
games and critical thinking
skills over that time.
This from institutions that are
"teaching you how to think."
Not so much.
And this is especially scary
when you consider that most
people going through this
four-year-type program,
they're in the age
range of about 18 to 22.
This is a time in our lives
when brain development is still
happening.
You would expect cognitive
critical thinking abilities
to be growing no matter
what you're doing.
So what is really
going on there?
Now this is what I
found in my research.
This is what I
documented in my book.
I found mountains of
data reaffirming story
after story of
people who felt bated
by the shiny promise of the
good life made by college
and then switched to
the soul-crushing debt
and dubious job prospects
that they actually got.
This is what led to
the second awakening.
This is what led me to
speak out and say, look,
the emperor is naked.
And I'm not alone
in saying that.
Clayton Christensen,
who teaches at Harvard,
he wrote the
"Innovator's Dilemma"
is on record saying that
he expects 50% of colleges
to be bankrupt in the
next 5 or 10 years.
I'm not quite that
optimistic, but I'm close.
Joseph Aoun, president of
Northeastern University,
wrote a great book
called "Robot Proof,"
talking about all the ways
in which higher education is
falling short when it
comes to preparing people
for the world of tomorrow.
Ryan Craig has written
a couple of great books
on the topic, "College
(Un)Bound" and "A New U."
Bryan Caplan has
written about this.
Many others have as well.
We all see that for too
long the cost of education
has been going up, and
the value it provides
has been going down.
Now this is a familiar pattern.
Costs going up,
value going down.
That's the definition
of a bubble,
and bubbles always burst.
Sometimes they
burst dramatically,
like the financial
markets did in 2008 Bang!
It's all gone, right?
3/4 of the value
disappears overnight.
But sometimes it's more gradual.
Sometimes the way a bubble
bursts is more like the air
being let out of a balloon.
[MAKES DEFLATION NOISE]
And we have good reason
to believe that this is
already happening when
it comes to higher education.
Over the last five years, the US
saw an undergraduate enrollment
decline of 2.4 million people.
That's almost 7% of would-be
students recognizing
that despite the huge power
commanded by the emperor,
he just isn't nearly
well-dressed enough
to justify investing years
of their lives and tens
if not hundreds of
thousands of their dollars.
So where does that leave us?
And what can we do?
Well, first, we can all be
smart about our own continuing
educations.
I'm not necessarily
unilaterally suggesting
that you forsake and condemn
institutionalized education.
But I am saying you
shouldn't take it
as a magical golden
ticket, either.
I'll get it, I'll pay the price,
and I'll just trust and hope
that things will work out.
The cost is just too high.
What other area of
life do we invest
that much time and
that much money
and just hope for the best?
Nowhere.
And regardless of
whatever formal training
you do or don't pursue,
you have to take ownership
and responsibility for
developing yourself
into the sort of
person who will thrive
in the modern world, someone who
is resourceful and thinks well
on their feet, who
takes initiative
and responsibility, who
handles ambiguity well,
and who plays well with others.
So how do you do that?
Well, I would love to give
you a set of instructions.
And people ask me, and that's
what they're looking for.
But I can't.
And there are two
reasons for that.
First, everybody's different.
What they find
fascinating, and inspiring,
and fulfilling won't be
the same for someone else.
But more importantly, how could
you possibly develop things
like resourcefulness,
initiative, and comfort
with ambiguity by
following someone else's
clean set of instructions?
It doesn't work.
What you need is a
shift in orientation.
You move away from
thinking like a navigator
towards thinking
like an explorer.
Navigators follow directions.
They're looking for the
shortest, or safest,
or most direct path from
A to B. Explorers aim
to learn because they're excited
about what they might find.
So how do explorers
get good at exploring?
By exploring.
You have a model
for this right here
at Google, your famous 20%
time for engineers, the idea
being that you should
be working on things
that are not core to your job.
You need to take that same
ethos to your own learning,
investing whether it's 20% or
whatever the appropriate time
is for you, of your time
and learning and growing
in areas that are not
immediately relevant
but are interesting, and
fascinating, and fulfilling.
And the world is abundant with
tools to help you do this.
There are books
and online courses.
There are Ted Talks.
There coaching programs.
There are personal
research projects.
There are
entrepreneurial ventures.
There are many ingredients.
But you have to invent
your own recipe.
And that's the key.
If you have kids, or
friends, or siblings
who are considering
college, I'm not
saying that they
should read some books
or watch some videos instead.
I'm not even saying
they shouldn't
go to college necessarily.
But the first step is to
be crystal clear about what
it is that you want.
And take the time to do it.
People can be forgiven
for, at the age of 17,
not knowing what they want to
do for the rest of their lives.
How many of us today would
like to be held responsible
and attached to some decision
we made when we were a teenager?
It's OK if they don't know.
But if you don't know,
take the time to find out.
Do a gap year.
Read a bunch of
books about things
you might be interested in.
Make a list of areas that
you might like to work in.
Reach out to people
working in those areas
and take them out
for lunch and say,
what is it like to
work in this area?
If you think this is a field
you want to pursue say, hey,
can I work for you for free,
for a month, or two months,
or three months?
All I want is to see what
it's like and get half an hour
of your time at the end
of the month to ask you
questions about what
this experience is like.
People sometimes tell me, Danny,
what do you mean work for free?
And I say that's a lot better
than paying tens of thousands
of dollars.
Get clear on what
it is that you want.
And sometimes something
funny will happen.
Sometimes this process will
bypass the rest altogether.
It will just lead
to a job offer.
And if that happens,
that's great,
but that's not the point.
Once you know what
it is you want to do,
you can decide on the
best path to get there.
Maybe college is the best path.
Someone who knows they
want to be a surgeon
will have to go
to medical school.
Someone who thinks they
want to be a surgeon
goes to medical school and then
discovers they don't like it--
and I know people like that--
that's unfortunate.
And many paths don't
require college
as the fastest way of getting
to where they want to go.
Fundamentally, some training,
some education is vocational.
It teaches you
how to do the job.
But in many cases, it's just
some generic calling card.
It's a degree that is supposed
to impress a very small number
of people in order
for them to open
a very small number of doors.
So if the goal is to impress
a very small number of people
and you're allocating
years of your life and tens
if not hundreds of thousands
of your dollars to doing it,
is there not potentially at
least a more efficient way
of getting the job done?
So for many people, college
will not be the answer.
And then the question
becomes, and I
get this question every day,
well, Danny, if not college,
then what?
And what people are asking
for with that question
is a one-size-fits
all answer, right?
If everyone doesn't
go to college,
everyone should go to
this thing instead.
But that's still the assembly
line model of education,
with everyone going
through the same stations.
And that doesn't fit our
era of personalization.
That's not how
things work anymore.
What we need is the
opposite of a one-size-fits
all approach, where
everyone follows
some right set of instructions.
And that leads us to the
most important ingredient,
which is self-direction.
It's not about opting out, and
quitting, and saying, well,
I'm just going to
watch TV and eat pizza.
It's about being
proactive in deciding,
here is what I'm going
to opt for instead.
It's about being
led by curiosity
and charting your own path.
And you need to do it.
Everybody needs to do it.
But before everyone can do it.
The people around them need
to trust that it can be done.
Because that's the terror.
Well, wait, no, I mean, people
left to their own devices
will just watch Netflix.
And people are reflecting
on a very limited subset
of their own experience.
They say, you know,
I work hard at work,
but when I get home at the end
of the day or on the weekend,
I just want to binge Netflix.
It's like, yeah, because you're
tired from your work all week
long.
But left to our own
devices people are curious.
People are interested.
People are engaged.
The research, everything
that we know about education
shows that A, people can do
this; and B, we must do this.
When we talk about deep
learning, powerful learning,
there's a lot of misconception
about how it works.
Many people have heard
of the 10,000-hour rule,
the idea if you want to become
an expert, master in a subject,
you have to work
for 10,000 hours.
This was popularized
by Malcolm Gladwell
in his book "Outliers."
This is a great, fascinating
interesting book.
He's incredibly talented.
And it is based largely on
the research of Dr. K Anders
Ericsson, who was so frustrated
by how misrepresented
his research was that he wrote
a book called "Peak," that talks
about deliberate practice.
There are three big steps
in any educational process.
The first is the
consumption of the new idea,
of the new knowledge.
That's where you're
attending the lecture,
watching the video, listening
to the audio, whatever it is.
The second step is application,
taking what you've learned
and doing something with it.
And that can be theoretical--
doing homework, writing essays,
whatever; it can be practical,
applying it in the real world.
And then the third step
is when you get feedback.
Here's where you got it right;
here's where you got it wrong.
This can come from a coach.
It can come from a teacher.
It can just come
from the real world.
I tried to sell
something nobody bought.
That tells me something.
Although, hopefully,
the feedback
is more directive and helpful
than just a binary yes or no.
Learning happens not in that
first bucket of exposure
to ideas.
It happens in the
second and third buckets
of playing with the
ideas, working with them,
applying them, getting
feedback, and improving.
It's about doing that
work and doing it
at the edge of
your comfort zone.
But it's hard to do that.
It's uncomfortable.
You're going to be pushing
out of your zone of comfort
all the time.
You're going to be doing
things that are difficult.
You're going to face setbacks.
And that means you
need to be able to push
through discomfort.
You need to persevere.
Now Angular Duckworth
calls this "Grit."
She published a book
about this recently,
but she published her first
research paper on the topic
in 2007.
And since then, the idea
of grit has inspired
the imagination of educators.
If grit leads to
success, then we just
have to teach people
to be more gritty.
But there's a key
thing that gets
missed, which is that nobody
is gritty about everything.
Nobody is gritty about things
that we have no interest in.
We are gritty about the
things that we care about.
We're greedy about the things
that fascinate and inspire us.
So while it's true that
grit is a cause of success,
grit is also an effect of
self-directed inspiration.
So for us to engage in that
deep and powerful learning
and push through
the discomfort, it
has to be on things and
in ways that actually
engage and fascinate us.
And that is what leads to
actual success in real life,
again, as documented
by research.
The key isn't to try to make
people greedy about things
that they don't care about.
It's to empower them to focus
their energies on the things
that they do.
Ultimately, we only
become the sort
of people who will succeed in
the present and in the future
if we get excited about learning
to figure it out on our own
and trust that we can.
I hope you will all do that.
I hope you will encourage the
people that you care about
to do the same.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: All right, questions.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I'm curious about the
role of social interaction
in institutional education.
I agree with your
assessment completely.
For the sake of argument,
I ended up at Yale,
and I'm grateful
for that opportunity
most because of the
people I met in my class.
And I think I've learned
the most in the last couple
of years from those people.
And to your point
about maybe it's
the ones who are destined
anyway who end up there,
where does that enter the
balance in the big picture?
DANNY INY: Oh, I
think it's huge.
I think it's incredibly
important and incredibly
valuable.
I would just
question-- and I mean,
everyone can kind of be
divided into two categories.
There are the people who have
functionally infinite resources
and the people who don't.
So is it easier to
just go to Yale,
where all these smart people
and great people already are?
Sure.
But does that convenience
justify the incredible cost
of going to Yale?
Maybe not.
Because if the whole goal is
to find all these great people,
and build relationships,
and develop the networks,
there are more efficient and
effective ways of doing that.
Like, a case in point, you
could move to New Haven
and hang out with students--
like, you can do things
without investing in all that.
So a lot of the component
pieces of higher education
are valuable, but the challenge
is that it's a bundle.
It's like, when
you had a cable--
you're going to get cable.
You get 427 channels.
You only really
want six of them.
But you're paying for
the other 421 as well.
And college has to be that way
because of the cost structure.
It's not an easy thing
for them to change.
So it's incredibly important
that they're probably
cheaper and faster
ways of getting just
as important pieces.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so I'm
totally bought-in.
You're the god of this thing.
And I'm, like, totally
into it to the point where
I like a side project, which
is an educational programs,
so I'm like fully immerse.
I've been doing this for
about a decade or so.
I have a nine-year-old now that
I'm shuffling through the New
York City public
school education system
and with the Manhattan
Upper East Side parents,
it's really hard
not to get caught up
in the whole culture and the
vision of what-- you know,
if I'm saying, like, college
is this terrible thing,
we should do it.
I shouldn't push my
kid into it, I also
feel like, well,
what if I'm wrong?
This is my child's
future that's,
like, really in my hands.
Like, she'll basically right
now buy into almost anything
I tell her.
I think part of the
problem I have is
that this ongoing
narrative that even
for my generation that we've
been telling ourselves,
which is like, oh I'm the first
in my family to go to college,
or I'm the second
generation to go to college.
My parents went to college.
I went to college.
There's something
that has built up.
And for me to come
in and say, but now,
my daughter will
not go to college.
I feel like there's
this downshift.
It's really hard to connect
those neurons and be OK with it
unless we had other
narratives around--
but Uncle Joe, he
didn't go to college,
and he's got this
successful business.
And then there's Cousin
Suzanne, and she did--
we just-- we don't
have the stories
in the kind of
middle class families
that I think something like
this is trying to touch.
So what do we do about that?
DANNY INY: So I
love that question,
which is really 11 questions.
And so I'll try to
cover all of it.
If I miss some, call me out,
and I'll try to come back to it.
So there's a lot in there.
Part of is it's very
hard to go against what
you've been taught and
trained and society around to
tells you feels right.
There's all this stuff out
there about follow your heart.
It's easy to follow your heart.
It's a lot harder
to follow your brain
when your heart, and your
feelings, and people around you
are telling you
something different.
I think it helps a lot to remind
yourself that the worst case
scenario is not that bad because
it is a reversible decision.
I don't think anyone
should make a unilateral,
I will never send
my kids to college.
I do think everyone
should move away
from the default, that option A
is that my kids go to college.
Let them chart their path,
figure out what makes sense.
And if it turns out
to be college, OK.
There are a lot of
other paths to success.
I also think there's an unfair
and unreasonable bar for going
to college versus not.
If you go to college, success
means you land a good job.
You make a high five-figure,
low six-figure income.
That's, like, you know,
the bar for success.
You say, well, I think I'm
not going to go to college.
And other people have
been successful not
going to college.
Yeah, but you're not Bill Gates.
You're not Mark Zuckerberg.
So if the bar for success
for going to college
is a six-figure
income, why is the bar
for success for not going to
college becoming a billionaire?
Like, that doesn't make sense.
That's not how ROI works.
So I would just keep
all of that in mind.
And the counterargument is--
one of the things
I didn't touch on
is that a big reason
why the value of college
is declined aside from the
internal actual value of what
it prepares you to do
and all that, college
has been a signal.
It's been a signal that,
look, the person who
bears this has gone through
certain experiences,
has certain wherewithal
and financial resources,
comes from a certain echelon of
society, et cetera, et cetera.
And the value of that
signal is declining
for all the reasons
we discussed, but also
because of ubiquity, right?
It used to be that you
apply for a job 40 years ago
and your rsum has MBA after
your name, you're the only one.
So you stand out.
If everyone has an
undergraduate degree,
you don't stand out at all.
And if you don't,
it might actually
be an interesting
differentiator.
Well, what has this
person does instead?
And so that's the reason
why it's gone down.
That said, that ubiquity
is kind of shift--
and that's part of why
the decline in the value--
it's kind of shifted
what the degree signals.
It used to say, look,
the bearer of this degree
is better than everyone else.
Now, it says, the
bearer of this degree
is no worse than anyone else.
And, unfortunately-- and I hate
to say this-- but for people
in society who are in a
position where they will not
be given the benefit
of the doubt,
where whether it's
women, whether it's
people of color,
people who are coming
from a disadvantaged
position, that stamp of, look,
you're no better
than everyone else
but you're no worse
than anyone else,
either, could have more value.
So I don't advocate
it in general.
And I think there
are good reasons to.
If you're going to
do it, find a way
to do it that is cost effective.
But that could skew the math.
SPEAKER: All right.
Can we keep going?
We're actually at time.
All right.
All right, so if you have any
questions, come talk to Danny.
[APPLAUSE]